tellement heureux de vous retrouver pour
un tout nouveau format tout nouveau
format où je vais vous aider à choisir
votre smartphone en fait c'est un
nouveau format c'est un guide je vais
vous faire tous les mois pour vous aider
à trouver le smartphone qui vous
convient en fait tout ça ça vient d'où
ça vient d'un constat vous me dites
souvent dans les commentaires lorsque je
fais une vidéo de test et d'ailleurs
dans plusieurs vidéos de test ok ça
c'est vachement cool mais celui-là est
bien tu dis que celui-là est bien tu dis
que je suis bien je sais plus lequel
choisir je sais plus lequel prendre j'ai
du mal à faire mon choix donc d'où
l'idée ça a moulinet je vous écoute vous
avez vu franchement je vous écoute d'où
l'idée de se dire ok bah tous les mois
on va faire un panorama de smartphone
que j'ai testé et je vais vous dire ok
il y a celui-là qui est comme ça il y a
celui-là mais peut-être que celui-là il
est là peut-être que celui-là il est
plus pour cette personne alors j'ai
essayé vraiment de le classifier par
tarif on va être à moins de 200 euros on
va être entre 200 et 500 € chez toute ma
liste qui est là on va être de 500 à 900
€ et puis les plus de 900 balles et au
milieu de ça il va y avoir des
smartphones plutôt orienté gaming donc
on va essayer de les regrouper on va
regrouper aussi bien évidemment les
smartphones qui se plie les smartphones
petit format pour ceux qui veulent
vraiment du tout petit format bref il y
en aura pour tout le monde à tous les
prix et ça c'est cool et une fois de
plus je parle uniquement de smartphone
que j'ai eu entre les mains que j'ai pu
tester que j'ai pu voir que j'ai pu
découvrir pour vous donner mon retour
l'idée c'est pas de faire une liste de
tout ce qui est sur le marché de choses
que je ne connaissais pas parce que mon
retour serait vraiment biaisé ce sont
des smartphones que j'ai eu donc voilà
d'ailleurs avis à toutes les marques si
vous voulez m'envoyer vos smartphones
pourquoi j'ai des cours envoyez-les
comme ça ça nourrira ce guide et on en
saura toujours plus et puis dernière
petite info juste avant de débuter c'est
un format que je débute maintenant donc
il y a probablement des choses qui
seront imparfaites des choses que je
vais améliorer dans le temps et puis je
vais mettre en place un site web pour
avoir aussi une vision globale pour vous
aider mais ça ça arrivera dans un temps
vraiment deux un peu plus lointain parce
qu'il y a quand même pas mal de choses à
faire et sachez que une fois de plus si
c'est smartphone vous intéresse je vous
mets dans la description et bien un lien
vers tous les produits si vous souhaitez
les acheter ce sont des liens
d'affiliation donc si vous cliquez
dessus c'est une petite comme ça me file
un coup de main ça vous en service et
gagner en gagnant ça c'est cool et puis
je vous envoie également le lien vers
mes vidéos YouTube pour en savoir plus
sur quel produit tel ou tel produit si
vous avez besoin de plus d'infos voilà
vous êtes prêt allez c'est parti
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec next mobile
vous avez été nombreux à aimer le bon
plan que je vous ai partagé il y a
quelques mois lors de la sortie des
galaxies S23 et next mobile fait en juin
c'est trois ans il y a cette occasion et
vous organise les meilleurs promos de
l'année alors je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez mais next mobile vous permet de
louer votre smartphone dans les
meilleures conditions et surtout sans
engagement elle super bon plan c'est que
vous profitez d'un iPhone 13 à 29,90 €
pendant 6 mois puis 39,90 € par mois
mais également des remis sur toute la
gamme des iPhone 14 dont l'iPhone 14 pro
à 49,90 € par mois pendant 6 mois puis
57 euros 90 par mois mais il y a
également le lancement des MacBook à la
location des 49,90 € par mois pour
rappel next mobile vous permet d'avoir
les derniers smartphones des tarifs
extrêmement accessibles les iPhone des
19,90 par mois et surtout de pouvoir les
tester sans engagement vous allez
pouvoir changer pour le modèle supérieur
tous les 12 mois sans frais ni hausse de
mensualité par exemple de l'iPhone 13 à
l'iPhone 14 et l'iPhone 14 au successeur
l'iPhone 14 12 mois après et vous avez
également une tranquillité d'esprit
grâce à l'assurance cassé vol incluse
savoir que le coût de réparation dans
simple écran peut monter jusqu'à 400
euros donc c'est quand même vachement
bien d'avoir ici cette assurance menex
mobile c'est également un modèle
éco-responsable ils vont reconditionner
les smartphones qu'ils ont loué en neuf
afin de leur donner une nouvelle vie et
tout ça et gérer en circuit court ici en
France et en plus de toutes ces promos
je vous partage le code Mr gros 10 il
vous donne 10 € sur votre première
commande tout s'accumulable avec toutes
les promotions en cours foncez donc sur
le site de Next mobile je vous mets un
lien quelque part en bas dans la
description et merci Alex mobile d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo on commence par
les moins de 100 euros et dans les
moines de 100 euros bon on va arriver
chez qui on va arriver chez Xiaomi alors
j'ai pas testé beaucoup de smartphone
dans les moins de 200 balles il y en a
un que j'ai vu qui est quand même assez
intéressant c'est celui-là regardez
c'est le redmi note 12 alors Xiaomi a
une gamme qui est tellement profonde au
niveau des raid minots ça devient un peu
fou fou il y a le ré mineur 12 ça c'est
un smartphone uniquement 4G vous avez la
version 5G c'est le pro la version 5G
qui est là qui est quand même un peu
plus cher vous avez la version Pro vous
avez la version Pro plus pour les
anciennes générations on en parle pas
parce que ça va me mettre trop de
produits on s'en sortirait pas mais
sachez que ce 12 il est quand même pas
mal intéressant et sur plusieurs points
je vous dis pourquoi déjà vous avez un
écran à molette 120 Hertz ça c'est cool
parce qu'il est quand même relativement
grand et en terme de visionnage de
contenu vous êtes tranquille il y a
assez de performance que ça dragonne 685
ça fonctionne vous avez une grosse
batterie mais de façon dans cette gamme
de prix toutes les batteries sont
grosses donc ça fonctionne de la
recharge rapide les caméras on va les
mettre un peu de côté il y a la 50
mégapixels qui est pas mauvaise mais le
reste c'est vraiment en dessous et c'est
pas fou fou pour autant vous avez quand
même pas mal de stockage pour mettre des
films des séries et compagnies bref
c'est un smartphone qui est très
équilibré qui est rien et que je peux
venir ici vous recommander puis surtout
n'oubliez pas que vous avez ce grand
écran de
6,67 pouces donc c'est vraiment un
smartphone que je vais recommander à
moins de 200 euros légèrement moins
199,90 si vous ne voulez pas forcément
d'abonnement 5G si vous voulez un
abonnement à coup réduit et si vous
voulez un super smartphone pour venir
visionner du contenu naviguer sur
Internet tranquillement avec suff
du côté de chez Samsung c'est le Galaxy
A14 alors je vous montre tout de suite
il est à 219 €, vous voyez il est même
moins cher que les deux modèles qu'on a
vu juste avant et qui a c'est
intéressant écran de 6,6 pouces donc ça
reste très grand c'est du full HD+ le
seul truc que je vais venir un peu
regretter par rapport au modèle de
Xiaomi c'est qu'ici vous êtes sur un
écran LCD alors que chez Xiaomi vous
êtes sur de la molette la différence
c'est quoi la molette c'est du OLED sur
les écrans OLED dès que vous avez un
pixel noir c'est un pixel éteint ça
permet d'économiser l'énergie surtout
d'abord on appelle les noirs profonds et
le contraste infini donc l'écran du
redmi note 12h30 notre 12 sera meilleur
que l'écran qu'on peut retrouver ici
chez Samsung avec son A14 je dirais que
la différence surtout c'est que vous
allez aller sur le A14 si vous voulez un
smartphone qui est un poil moins cher
que les Rémi note 12 mais que vous
préférez l'expérience logiciel de
Samsung qui pour moi aujourd'hui une des
meilleures ou un nuage dans sa chambre
sur l'appareil photo vous avez un
capteur principal de 50 mégapixels mais
si vous allez voir mon test d'aller voir
qu'en photo bon c'est très poussif c'est
pas extraordinaire après l'avantage
c'est que vous avez également une
batterie de 5000 milliards ici bon ça
c'est assez classique alors il est pas
mauvais c'est la 14 mais c'est vrai
quand on regarde en face ce que fait
Xiaomi a un peu plus cher on a tendance
à vouloir aller sur un redmi note par
exemple 4G vous voyez je vous l'ai dit
lié à 239 €. donc moi j'irai plus sur le
redmi note 12 4G et si vous pouvez
mettre un peu plus d'argent je dirais
sur le redmi note 12 5G il y a 279 par
rapport au Samsung Galaxy A14 que je
trouve un poil un poil en tout cas quand
même après si vous vous en foutez de la
photo et que vous voulez juste de la
performance brute il y a un truc qui est
vachement bon c'est poco vous allez sur
le poco X5 g il y a une version pro mais
c'est pas la version Pro celle là autant
la photo est un peu aux fraises elle est
pas folle folle correcte attention c'est
correct mais c'est pas fou autant par
contre vous avez de la performance c'est
pas mal on a un stade dragon 695 ok ça
fonctionne on est juste au dessus de
celui du redmi note 12 vous voyez c'est
un dragon 685 vous avez cet écran AMOLED
120 Hertz donc ça pour le gaming aussi
c'est bien la recharge rapide 33 watts
qui est cool et vous êtes à 279 euros 90
en fait vous êtes au même tarif que le
redmi note 12 5G ici chez poco après ils
ont fait tout un gros boulot au niveau
résolution tactile c'est vraiment des
smartphones qui sont faits pour le
gaming donc si vous voulez venir jouer
là-dessus si vraiment un produit que
j'aimerais vous recommander un tarif qui
reste maîtriser alors pour le gaming
après le max du gaming on ira sur le
rock phone on le verra un peu plus loin
mais surtout beaucoup plus cher mais
l'expérience et si elle est quand même
pas dégueu du tout après si vous voulez
aller plus loin il y a le modèle Pro
alors le modèle Pro s'envoie du pâté
vous êtes sur un stade dragon 778 g j'ai
pour gaming c'est l'appellation chez
Qualcom également un écran AMOLED 120
Hertz ça marche pour la caméra
principale remonte entre 8 mégapixels
mais très honnêtement il vous le marque
de qualité professionnelle ça c'est
juste du marketing j'irai voir ma vidéo
c'est pas mauvais mais bon voilà on
augmente surtout la charge on va un peu
plus vite en 67 watts c'est cool après
il vous met tout le truc vous êtes sur
de la RAM en 3.0 ok c'est pas mal c'est
rapide ça fonctionne vous avez de la RAM
virtuelle on peut venir augmenter en
plus la RAM ça ok bon ça c'est c'est du
software mais ça fonctionne bon les
photos on passe très rapidement c'est un
smartphone qui est vraiment pas mal un
c'est un très très bon rapport qualité
prix pour le gaming et je vous le dis
ici on se situe à 129 euros 90 une fois
de plus vous avez tous les liens en bas
dans la description il y en a un autre
qui est pas mal qui a
0 pour pas boucher on va si ils vont pas
bouger on va vérifier ouais c'est
celui-là c'est le one 5 like et pourquoi
il est pas mal parce que alors celui-là
je trouve un peu plus élégant que le
poco qui reste jolie attention mais un
peu plus élégant un peu plus fin un peu
plus raffiné on a un écran qui est
incurvé sur le côté le module photo est
pas mal c'est une vraie symétrie c'est
le Magic 5 Lite la batterie soit un poil
plus grosse mais franchement ça change
pas grand-chose à 5100 million par heure
vous avez un écran OLED OLED à Molay
même combat ok ça marche 120 Hertz
pareil même combat ça fonctionne vous
avez le même système de RAM au niveau
soft qui va être boosté 8 plus 5 grâce
au soft surtout il est très très fin il
est très joli j'aime bien celui-là aussi
et à côté qui est assez premium ça c'est
vrai les courbure l'écran mais ça c'est
tout le marketing que nous montre la
marque mais je l'aime bien alors il sera
peut-être un peu moins orienté gaming
dans l'expérience mais pour autant il en
fera tout autant ça c'est pas mal tous
tactile vous voyez à 300 Hertz bon on va
éviter le truc un peu trop technique et
rébarbatif mais ça reste un très très
bon smartphone il va être là pour lutter
contre la lumière bleue anti sentiment
et léger qui est performant et qui est
très bien aussi donc ça c'est cool et
c'est un smartphone que vraiment je peux
venir vous recommander et je vous le dis
état vous allez noter juste ici
329,90 €. donc si vous voulez plus aller
côté gaming vous allez aller chez poco
avec le X5 pro 5g et si vous voulez un
smartphone un peu plus lifestyle un peu
plus raffiné guillemets quand je dis ça
vous allez chez Honor avec le Magic
saint-light il est exactement au même
tarif et que personnellement j'aime bien
aussi ensuite on vient de monter encore
un petit peu en tarif on est un peu
moins de 400 balles et avec Samsung le
Galaxy A34 5G à 399 € alors on va un peu
plus haut on va améliorer la qualité
photo une fois de plus j'ai fait un test
le lien est dans la description on reste
un peu dans les mêmes propositions c'est
à dire un grand écran de 6,6 pouces là
on passe sur du Super AMOLED 120 Hertz
alors qu'avant chez Samsung on était sur
du LCD donc là il y a un gap c'est pas
mal on fait de la photo en 48 mégapixels
la qualité est quand même meilleur donc
ça c'est pas mal non plus vous voyez il
faut arriver un peu moins de 400 balles
pour que je sais Samsung on est de la
molette alors qu'avant on en avait pas
donc ça ça fait bon vous voyez c'est un
peu un peu dommage vous voulez avoir un
peu leur copie là-dessus pour autant le
smartphone est bien les photos sont
correctes sur le capteur principal le
respect tard c'est vraiment lui qui va
être meilleur et une fois de plus on va
y aller si on veut vraiment l'expérience
écosystème Samsung avec d'un côté les
montres connectées avec de l'autre côté
le PC avec toute l'expérience Smart
things pour la maison connectée parce
que c'est vraiment aussi un des gros
points forts qu'on peut venir retrouver
chez Samsung ici avec les buzz enfin
bref c'est très complet ça ça marche
vachement bien ça smartphone que j'ai
bien aimé testé et que je trouve pas mal
à 399 €. après au même tarif vous avez
Xiaomi avec son redmi note 12 Pro 5G bon
on est au-dessus des autres au niveau au
niveau des autres produits de la gamme
redmi note 12 4G 5G pro 5G donc là on
est à 399 €. et à ce tarif là c'est pas
mal non plus on reste sur un écran
AMOLED 120 vous avez de la charge 67
watts ça c'est rapide c'est pas mal non
plus on la batterie une fois de plus
5000 milliards je vous l'ai dit c'est un
très très grand standard ici ils vous
ont mis un capteur de Sony c'est l'immx
766 qui est pas dégueu donc ça c'est
cool et là on a un processeur
médiathèque c'est le dimensity 1080 qui
est en 5g et c'est un smartphone que je
trouve bien une fois de plus bien
positionné avec plein de belles specs à
l'intérieur et qui est franchement pas
dégueu donc une fois de plus si vous
voulez en savoir plus je vous renvoie à
mon test pour le découvrir bon après
l'ultra grand-angle il a Macron
globalement on s'en fout mais c'est pas
principal il est pas mauvais ça c'est
assez bien fichu ça vous donne de de
belles images et c'est souvent ce que
fait Xiaomi c'est-à-dire que il se mette
face aux concurrents au même tarif et
ils viennent booster la fiche technique
pour essayer de remporter un peu le
marché et là-dessus on sort quand même
plutôt pas mal donc si vous aimez
l'écosystème Samsung pouvez aller chez
Samsung avec Galaxy A34 si vous voulez
une fiche technique un peu booster vous
pouvez aller chercher omis sur le redmi
note 12 Pro 5G qui est aussi vachement
cool et après ils vous en ont sorti
encore un autre ils aiment bien avoir
une gamme qui est qui est folle ici
c'est le redmi note 12 Pro plus 5G
469 euros on vient quand même augmenter
significativement le tarif là il vient
d'augmenter un peu la fiche tech c'est
voilà ils en font toujours un peu plus
avec une caméra de 200 mégapixels bon ok
la recharge très rapide 120 watts c'est
un argument très très fort dans cette
gamme de prix toujours la même batterie
de 5000 empereur mais ça je vous l'ai
dit c'est standard on garde là
exactement le même processeur
médiathèque le 10-mensity 1085g ok bon
l'écran 120 Hertz ça reste la même chose
donc la fiche technique reste à peu près
la même une fois de plus allez jeter un
coup d’œil directement à ma vidéo test
pour en savoir plus le 8 megap la caméra
macro une fois de plus on s'en fout
après c'est toutes les petites images
voilà pour emmener des c'est mieux ce
qu'on fait on fait ça vachement bien
c'est du marketing sur leur site mais ça
reste un smartphone qui est quand même
vachement cool et qui est pas mal et ça
je vous le dis on se situe au tarif de
469 € 90 €. ça reste quand même un peu
d'argent mais voyez le truc que fait
chier omis là où ils sont extrêmement
malins et qui viennent vraiment étendre
leur gamme redmi qui est la gamme où ils
vendent le plus de smartphone en soyons
clairs et pas sur la gamme Xiaomi les
Xiaomi 13 et compagnons c'est la gamme
redmi c'est là où ils en font énormément
et elle devient encore plus large cette
gamme on commence un peu plus de 200
balles jusqu'à un peu moins de 500 euros
comme ça ils se mettent en face de tous
les concurrents dans cette gamme de prix
pour faire du volume faire du volume
faire du volume mais les smartphones
sont très très très sérieux et ça c'est
quand même pas mal non plus après j'en
ai un autre qui est vraiment pas mal si
vous êtes orienté gaming c'est chez poco
c'est le F5 alors il vous le marque le
flash cheap killer bon ok mais par
contre la fiche mec elle fait vraiment
pas rigoler snap dragon 7 plus gêne 2
très sérieux écran à flot à molette bon
ok 120 ça marche capteur principal 64
mégapixels c'est bien sûr vous
comprendrez que chez poco les photos
c'est pas trop ça mais globalement ça
fait le taf le prof c'est cool donc ça
franchement pour le gaming il y a rien à
dire technologie de refroidissement bon
ils veulent vraiment mettre le paquet au
niveau marketing sur tout ce qui va être
gaming parce que c'est leur cœur de
cible ici la RAM c'est aussi très
sérieux lpdr 5 ufs 3.1 c'est très très
bien et c'est ce qui faut globalement
vous voyez on monte jusqu'à 12 et 256
donc globalement ici rien à dire
extension aussi de la RAM dynamiquement
grâce au soft mais d'aller un peu plus
vite bon ok d'apporter un peu fluidité
ok why not la photo on passe très
rapidement parce que c'est pas vraiment
ce qu'on va venir rechercher sur ce
smartphone mais voyez dans cette gamme
de prix je trouve très très bien
positionné le F5 donc si vous vous avez
un peu plus de budget que sur les autres
je vous ai dit il y a 279 et 329 pour
les X5 et X5 Pro vous pouvez monter
jusqu'à un peu moins de 500 balles vous
avez le F5 qui est cool et vous verrez
il y a la version Pro mais là en dessous
de 500 euros donc on en parle dans
quelques instants après j'ai un autre
smartphone qui est vraiment un
smartphone coup de cœur c'est le
smartphone de Nothing c'est le phone one
que j'adore alors lui il est un peu plus
disruptif c'est à dire que il y a
vraiment un design particulier il y a
tout ce jeu de lumière derrière avec la
glyphe interface il y a des sonneries
qui sont un peu différentes tu
l'interface qui est très différente
c'est très typé mais si vous voulez un
smartphone pas comme les autres un
smartphone que les gens n'ont pas même
s'ils en ont vendu beaucoup et ça c'est
vachement bien mais c'est pas les
smartphones qu'on va voir le plus entre
les mains de de ses potes à droite à
gauche et bien vous pouvez y aller parce
que franchement il est trop trop cool il
est super beau il est bien pensé il est
différent il est design l'interface elle
est vachement cool et no sing a super
bien bosser là-dessus moi c'est vraiment
un smartphone que j'ai adoré voyez ils
ont pris le risque des guillemets quand
je dis ça de vous mettre deux capteurs
en se disant tout le monde met trois
capteurs dans cette gamme de prix mais
globalement c'est assez bullshit parce
que la macro on s'en fout ça n'apporte
strictement rien nous on va mettre
l'essentiel et ce qui marche est-ce
qu'ils ont mis ça fonctionne c'est
correct vous voulez en savoir plus une
fois de plus je vous renvoie à ma vidéo
mais voyez vous avez un écran OLED 10,55
pouces et la différence par rapport à
tous les autres qui vont mettre des
titres en grand regardez par ce Xiaomi
vous avez les grands trucs à droite à
gauche c'est très très clair eux c'est
assez minimaliste et ça me fait marrer
parce que regardez un milliard de
couleurs OLED 6 55 pouces HDS plus c'est
écrit tout petit 120 Hertz adaptatif
c'est écrit tout petit voilà on dirait
des femmes qui sont foot mais non c'est
parti pris tout est vraiment réfléchi et
je trouve ça bien donc ils ont vraiment
bien bossé vous avez un smartphone qui
est puissant qui est cool qui est très
différent et que personnellement j'aime
bien ici d'autant plus qu'ils ont
annoncé il y a le phone tout qui devrait
arriver bientôt avec un processeur de
quoi comme à l'intérieur qui va pas
faire rigoler et ça va être performant
ça veut vraiment pas mal donc vous voyez
ça c'est si vous voulez un smartphone
qui est pas comme les autres vous pouvez
vraiment aller sur le nothing phone one
et qui est aujourd'hui au tarif de 469
euros voilà si vous voulez vraiment
quelque chose de très différent très
différenciant avec une expérience qui
est venue nulle part enfin one mais si
vous voulez un des smartphones qui
rassurent qui est un des best-sellers
c'est le Galaxy A54 5G ça reste une
gamme de smartphone qui marche le mieux
Galaxy a53 à 52 à Saint-Quentin tout ça
les smartphones qu'ils ont le mieux chez
Samsung sur les smartphones ils font le
plus de volume parce que vous avez toute
l'expérience Samsung le A54 en photo il
est vraiment bien il marche super bien
l'écran est bien il y a de la
performance il y a un super rapport
qualité prix vous avez one uhi
l'expérience logiciel qui est vraiment
top bref c'est le smartphone de Samsung
qu'on peut venir recommander un tarif
assez maîtrisé même si ça s'emballe ça
reste un certain budget globalement je
vous le dis écran de 6,4 pouces toujours
un peu les mêmes tailles en fait ça
c'est toujours un peu la même chose le
capteur qui est très très bien bon ok 67
ok 2 jours d'autonomie c'est une grosse
batterie de 5000 je pense aussi ici je
vais pas pris la fiche technique Parker
mais globalement toujours un peu la même
la même histoire et c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très très sérieux 8 Go
de RAM 128 Go de stockage bah la
batterie de 5000 milliards donc vraiment
ici vous avez deux quoi faire c'est un
super smartphone c'est le smartphone qui
est souvent qui rassure c'est souvent
Samsung la marque qui rassure parce que
c'est la marque leader et les personnes
qui s'y connaissent pas trop vont chez
Samsung mais ça marche bien et il y a
aucun problème avec ça donc si vous
voulez un bon smartphone à 499 € très
équilibré gaming visionnage écouter de
la musique naviguer sur Internet les
réseaux sociaux
la création de contenu avoir de bonnes
photos de la vidéo cool Galaxy à 54 5G
sans problème il y a un autre produit
qui est très cool aussi en face qui est
un peu différent c'est au nord c'est la
marque qui monte énormément alors vous
refaire très rapidement au nord était
avec Huawei avant Huawei c'est séparé de
Honor honoraires et les services Google
et au nord revient vraiment fort avec
des produits très cool donc le Honor 70
donc je vous ai déjà parlé l'année
dernière vous le mette toujours pas la
même histoire des grands écrans de 6,67
pouces oui c'est très précis 6 67 pouces
parce qu'ils ont tous la même
fournisseur avec les mêmes tailles
d'écran c'est du 120 Hertz c'est de la
recharge rapide une batterie de 4800
milliampères heure bon ça aurait pu être
5000 mais c'est quasiment la même
histoire vraiment orienté sur la photo
et la création de contenu c'est vraiment
ce que veut raconter ici au nord comme
histoire avec une amie 800 ça c'est cool
54 mégapixels un ultra grand angle en 50
mégapixels qui fait Macron également
donc là la macro ça devient intéressant
de mégapixels pour la profondeur de
champ bon kiwhy not le fameux mode solo
cut que je vous ai déjà présenté qui est
pas mal qui est pas mal on la création
de contenu un côté un peu marketing pour
venir raconter une nouvelle histoire
mais c'est pas mal et puis je trouve
jolie ils ont vraiment un truc très
sympa au niveau de l'asymétrie des
jolies smartphones chez chez Honor ici
donc ils ont vraiment pas à rougir donc
une fois de plus on est un petit peu
moins de 500 balles 499,90 € vraiment un
petit peu moins de 500 balles donc si
vous intéresse vous faites plus le lien
est en bas dans la dans la description
c'est bien allez on arrive dans les plus
de 500 balles euh plus de 500 balles
gros coup de cœur sur le pixel 7a qui
est juste magnifique toute l'expérience
Google c'est de l'Android pur euh les
futurs drop c'est à dire des nouveautés
logiciels qui sont rajoutés tous les
trois mois sans même que Google vous le
dise vous avez de nouvelles
fonctionnalités il est un tarif très
maîtrisé de 509 euros il est super bon
en photo bref c'est vraiment un des
smartphones que je n'ai recommandé ici
vous avez par contre la puce Google
c'est la tensor G2 vous avez aussi leur
plus de sécurité à l'intérieur alors
attention c'est pas là où on va voir le
processeur le plus puissant orienté
gaming soyons clair pas du tout ici ça
va être un vrai bon processeur qui va
être plus orienté expérience Google tout
ce que vous voulez faire avec Google si
vous voulez vraiment un smartphone
orienté performance ça va pas
nécessairement être celui-là qui vous
faut mais par contre quand même tourner
vachement de jeu sans aucun problème
après autre produit qui est cool c'est
un peu différent c'est l'iPhone se on
arrive chez Apple alors si on va sur un
iPhone c'est que on veut iOS soyons
clairs mais l'iPhone se reste cool
malgré le design qui est le design
ancien d'Apple avec
Digital en bas qui est un peu moins fou
on préfère la facidine on l'a pas ici
mais pour autant voyez il est à partir
de 559 alors choisissez une couleur hop
on s'en fout à partir de 559 € donc ça
c'est quand même vachement cool version
64 Go donc si vous voulez un iPhone pour
acheter pas trop cher donc si ça reste
quand même beaucoup d'argent 559 €, on
se parle ici que de produits en neuf pas
de produits reconditionné chose qu'on
verra un peu plus tard alors je vous en
parlais tout à l'heure il y a également
le le grand frère du pourquoi F5 le poco
F5 pro qui à partir de 579 euros 90 qui
est très cool qui va aller un peu plus
loin là vous avez le meilleur processeur
de l'année dernière c'est-à-dire le
saint dragon 8 plus Jane 1 vous avez un
écran que la résolution de deux cas
c'est de la molette c'est très très bon
du 120 Hertz de la recharge rapide 30
watts la caméra 64 mégapixels bon ok
mais une fois de plus je vous le dis
poko il est pas là pour la photo mais là
vous avez une fiche technique
surpuissante vous avez beaucoup beaucoup
de performances ici le refroidissement
la grosse batterie
techno qui vont bien en termes de RAM et
de stockage bref un smartphone qui est
super bien pour le gaming qui est je
vous le dis à
579,90 € donc à un peu moins de 600
balles vous avez un super smartphone
orienté gaming signé poco ça c'est
chouette après j'ai un smartphone qui a
baissé ontarif alors là je l'ai à
combien 649 € mais je l'ai trouvé moins
cher je l'ai trouvé à 569 € une fois
plus je mets tous les liens bas dans la
description c'est pixel 7 qui reste très
très bon alors une fois de plus c'est
plus pour du Google mais c'est un écran
de 6,63 pouces qui est très bon qui
marche bien vous avez la puce Google
sensor G2 donc si vous voulez du Google
et que vous voulez une super expérience
Google vous avez celui-là sarifa qui est
très très bien et alors après il y a une
marque qui est aussi pas mal qui qui
monte qui s'améliore vraiment c'est
Motorola avec son Edge 40 et le Edge 40
il est à 599 € alors ils sont améliorés
en photo c'était souvent un peu le point
faible celui-là il est intéressant sur
sur différents points c'est à dire que
si vous voulez pas déjà une marque
asiatique que vous voulez une marque
américaine et vous aimez pas forcément
ni google ni Apple bah vous êtes
Motorola voilà vous savez soyons clairs
on est là dessus le soft mental les
photos se sont améliorées ils ont une
proposition qui est intéressante avec ce
F40 et ils ont surtout un truc qui est
pas mal en plus pour les professionnels
vous permet de venir à connecter votre
smartphone un moniteur à une télé pour
pouvoir profiter d'une expérience de
bureautique pour du gaming également des
portées donc ça c'est pas mal ils ont eu
aussi une super stabilisation qui est
vraiment pas mal pour le coup si vous
voulez venir filmer un très gros point
fort qu'ils ont sur ce sur ce smartphone
là batterie de 4400 milliampères heure
de la charge 68 watts donc c'est ça
fonctionne médiathèque des men City a eu
8020 bon voilà on est on est dans ce
qu'on attend un smartphone dans cette
gamme de prix j'ai un truc qui est très
très bon très très bon bon plan j'ai le
Galaxy Z flip 3 alors là je l'ai pas sur
le site de Samsung parce qu'il est plus
référencé j'ai que le 4 et le Z flip 3
j'ai trouvé à
618,88 € alors c'est un smartphone un
peu ancien mais je vous le propose quand
même parce que il reste intéressant si
vous voulez un smartphone pliable de
Samsung pas trop cher à 618 euros
franchement il vaut le coup une fois de
plus je vous mets le lien en bas dans la
description il y en a un autre qui canon
c'est à dire que si vous voulez un
smartphone avec un petit format vous
voulez pas un gros format vous voulez
plutôt un petit écran et bien il y a le
zenfone 9 d'Asus qui est cool
franchement qui est cool qui est j'ai
trouvé à 619 euros même si là je te
propose à 729 j'ai trouvé un tarif pas
trop trop élevé et là par contre vous
avez un truc qui est vraiment bien c'est
que une fois de plus c'est un tout petit
écran
5,9 pouces on est en dessous des 6
pouces c'est assez niché mais si vous
cherchez un smartphone avec un petit
écran et un petit format vous avez le
zenfone 9 vous avez l'iPhone se et vous
l'avez vu tout le reste c'est du 6,6
pouces ça reste quand même très grand
donc là c'est vraiment un smartphone qui
est un peu plus niché mais qui reste
très performant très bien très
accessible qui fait de bonnes photos et
qui est un super rapport qualité prix
après on monte en tarif avec le pixel 7
Pro qui reste aussi un excellent
smartphone et là on est à 889 euros je
l'ai trouvé à 769 euros donc une fois de
plus je vous mets les liens juste en bas
dans la description exactement la même
chose sous le capot que le pixel 7 et
que le pixel 7a mais on va aller plus
loin au niveau des capteurs photos avec
un grand écran plus grand écran enfin
bref donc le meilleur de l'expérience
Google ici le tarif est aussi un peu
plus élevé mais la globalement ça fait
pas rire alors deux smartphones qui sont
assez intéressants ici le Xiaomi 12 T et
le Xia 12 tes pros qu'on va avoir ici
qui sont cool pourquoi parce que ça
reste des smartphones très récents du
côté de chez Xiaomi 649 euros pour l'un
et pour l'autre on est à 799 euros mais
vous avez des smartphones qui sont très
performants du côté de chez Xiaomi vous
avez tout ce qui va bien à l'intérieur
c'est pas les smartphones une fois de
plus qui vont se vendre le plus sécher
au mi c'est plus la gamme redmi mais qui
sont très sérieux sur le 12 t vous avez
un demon City 8100 ultra qui
fonctionnent bien grand capteur de 108
mégapixels tandis que sur l'autre modèle
vous le mettre là la photo de son
mégapixels bref je vais pas vous faire
une lecture de fiche technique mais si
vous aimez Xiaomi si vous voulez un
produit de Xiaomi avec de la performance
Xiaomi dans cette gamme de prix et bien
c'est un peu les seuls qu'on va venir
retrouver de la marque que je trouve pas
mal globalement il y a notre produit qui
est pas mal c'est le Motorola le Edge 40
pro 899 € voyons on vient tout de suite
monter monter et monter les les tarifs
et que je trouve pas mal ils sont
vraiment ça très très jolis produits
incurvés des quatre côtés la photo est
pas mal du tout bon il y a de la 5G on
s'en doutera il y a de la performance
bref il tout ce qu'il faut sous le sous
le capot ce smartphone autant avant je
vous le dis une fois de plus les photos
étaient pas folle autant ils sont quand
même améliorés d'excellent stabilisation
pour la vidéo donc ça fait qu'on peut
venir recommander ce smartphone avec de
la charge sans fil 15 watts pour moi il
est sérieux oui on est sur les mêmes
tailles des courses ils ont tous les
mêmes tailles d'écran c'est une dalle
polaire c'est l'olive parce qu'il faut
retenir 6 67 pouces on va jusqu'à 165 h
donc pour le gaming c'est très très cool
et c'est un super smartphone d'ailleurs
j'en profite pour vous le dire mais ils
ont leur smartphone pliable client Razer
de 2022 est tombé qui est aussi à 899 €.
alors c'est pas celui-là que j'aimerais
recommander immédiatement soyons clairs
j'irai plus sur un Galaxy Z flip 3 ou un
Z flip 4 mais si vous aimez la marque
pourquoi pas après il y a une autre
marque je suis un peu embêtée c'est
oneplus 115g et pas mauvais mais j'ai
trouvé un peu en dessous en photo j'ai
trouvé un peu décevant donc bon 849
euros si vous aimez oneplus si vous
aimez l'expérience au logiciel oneplus
vous pouvez y aller c'est pas trop votre
truc
je me posais la question alors il y a
une marque dont je vous ai pas parlé
jusqu'à présent je suis un peu embêté
alors je vous le montre parce que
c'était mon smartphone coup de coeur
l'année dernière parce que il y a plein
de rumeurs qui disent que oppo serait
sur le départ en France et en Europe
pour l'instant rien n'est confirmé par
la marque vous dit non non on reste on
est là mais voyez quelques indicateurs
qui fait que je me pose la question et
que je peux difficilement aujourd'hui
venir vous recommander de l'eau pot
néanmoins et je vous le dis quand même
pour moi le finding 5 Pro c'était mon
coup de cœur l'année dernière excellence
smartphone d'ailleurs ils le vend même
pas sur leur site si on va acheter un
coup d'oeil par exemple sur Amazon il
sort à combien le finding 5 Pro find 5
Pro actuellement indisponible vous voyez
la question on a la réponse c'est
dommage parce que c'est vraiment super
smartphone alors on continue du côté des
iPhone une fois de plus si vous voulez
iOS si vous voulez un smartphone qui a
déjà deux générations l'iPhone 12 il
reste très cool et c'est un super
smartphone très performant donc vous
avez aucun problème même s'il a deux
générations l'iPhone 12 il est bien il
est disponible à partir de 809 euros en
neufs et une fois de plus je vous
reparle pas aujourd'hui encore du
reconditionné mais probablement un peu
plus tard faut que je trouve une façon
de avoir un format peut-être un peu plus
condensé sinon on va pas s'en sortir
j'ai une vidéo qui est très très longue
ça reste un très beau produit vous voyez
on a
[Musique]
avec des propositions cool le Xiaomi 13
en fait partie très cool le partenariat
avec Leica donc si vous aimez les cas si
vous aimez la photo si vous aimez les
portraits ils ont des choix des fois qui
sont un peu particulier mais pourquoi
pas aller voir mon test parce que moi je
trouve qu'il y a un truc qui est très
très sympa avec ce smartphone si vous
aimez Xiaomi si vous connaissez Xiaomi
et si vous avez 1000 balles de budget et
que vous voulez vous faire plaisir sur
maîtresse clairement après vous avez ici
au maîtresse pro qui est l'excellence
chez Xiaomi donc si vous vous cherchez
ce que aujourd'hui Xiaomi fait mieux
avec les cas en terme de photos super
d'écran bref vous avez tout ce qu'il
faut ici c'est un dragon 8 GN2 vous avez
un écran AMOLED wqhd Plus 120 Hertz bref
ça déconne pas c'est puissant ses
performant ça marche bien les photos
sont belles c'est un très joli
smartphone qui est disponible un petit
peu moins de 1300 euros c'est un certain
prix mais sans doute après on va bien
voir du côté des galaxies S23 c'était la
grande nouveauté en début d'année Galaxy
S23 voyez il est déjà un peu moins cher
il était à 959 il est tombé à 899 et moi
j'avais 1019 voyez bon que je sais pas
pourquoi donc il est moins cher c'est
intéressant un smartphone qui est bien
un smartphone qui est très bon en photo
qui est très équilibré qui est très cool
donc si vous cherchez le plus haut de
gamme aujourd'hui chez une marque qui
rassure énormément c'est à dire Samsung
Galaxy S23 il y a pas déception et un
peu moins de 900 balles franchement ça
vaut le coup il aura pris il y a des
couleurs exclusives vous le voyez il y a
le Galaxy S23 plus qui est aussi pas mal
les prix ont baissé au lieu de 1339 € on
est à 1159 € et aussi un excellent
smartphone et ça marche bien surtout
pour moi le plus beau aujourd'hui qui
est mon coup de cœur pour l'instant sur
ce début d'année c'est le Galaxy S23
ultra je les ai pas tous vu pas tous
essayé notamment Sony j'ai pas encore vu
leur smartphone donc on en parlera un
peu plus tard mais le S23 ultra il a une
douceur au niveau de la photo il est
beau l'écran est magnifique il était à
1419 il est passé à 1299 pour moi ça
vaut le coup alors si je devais faire le
choix voyez entre le Xiaomi 13 pro à
1299 et le Galaxy S23 ultra à 1299
j'irai sur le Galaxy S23 ultra parce que
il est absolument incroyable autre
smartphone qui est top au niveau de la
photo au niveau de la vidéo c'est le
Honor Magic 5 Pro alors c'est une marque
qui remonte qui reprogresse qu'on
connaît un peu moins mais qui est une
marque absolument dingue qui a des
scores de fou chez dxma 152 au niveau du
classement caméra niveau de l'écran 151
l'écran est top incurvé à des quatre
côtés le rendu photo est magnifique il y
a des algo de dingue derrière c'est
vraiment un super smartphone donc ça
c'est aussi un smartphone que je peux
vraiment venir recommander alors
aujourd'hui il le propose à quel tarif
il le propose il le propose il le
propose à 1199 euros ça va être hyper
dur de venir départager entre d'un côté
un Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra et un Honor
Magic 5 Pro les deux sont magnifiques
les deux font de belles photos les deux
sont cool on va les prendre après de
vous est-ce que vous aimez ce côté un
petit peu bulle sur l'écran avec ses
doubles caméra ici vous avez une
reconnaissance de votre visage en trois
dimensions ce que n'a pas le Galaxy S23
ultra vous voyez on est sur des petits
détails l'écran est incurvé des quatre
côtés ce que n'a pas le Galaxy S23 ultra
mais le Galaxy S23 ultra tellement sous
le capot notamment ce temps dragon 8
gène 2 on retrouve ici aussi sur ce
smartphone et c'est ça qui est très dur
très haut de gamme c'est à dire que ils
sont top partout c'est une question
d'affinité avec la marque c'est une
question d'affinité avec l'OS une
question d'écosystème est-ce que vous
avez déjà des produits d'une marque ou
pas les deux sont très très bons et je
dois reconnaître que le Honor Magic 5
Pro reste aussi un des smartphones que
j'adore on se début d'année 2023 leur
marque qui m'a regardé dessus mais un
peu surpris c'est vivo avec son x 90 pro
qui reste un bon smartphone attention
vivo aujourd'hui le propose un peu moins
cher il était à 1199 il est tombé à 1099
bon au moins 8%, c'est une petite remise
c'est toujours cette prix il est bien au
niveau de la photo avec les optiques ice
ça marche bien il y a de la performance
mais en fait il y a des trucs qu'on
avait avec le X80 pro qu'on a perdu ici
notamment le très grand capteur
d'empreintes digitale qui a été situé
sous l'écran alors on l'a toujours plus
petit mais on n'a pas toutes les petites
fonctionnalités qu'on a avec il y a
quelques petits trucs qui ont disparu
pour autant ça reste un très bon
smartphone mais voyez quand je regarde
dans cette gamme de prix j'aurais plus
tendance à aller sur un smartphone de
Honor ou un smartphone de Samsung que
sur le vivo et même s'il est très bien
il va moins me séduire après c'est ma
faute que j'adore si vous voulez une
superbe expérience gaming avec des
accessoires de fou et bien c'est le
rockfon set alors il y a le 7 ultimate
mais bon il est quand même très très
cher ok on va pas aller dessus on va
regarder le rock fan 7 et le rock fan 7
je peux vous assurer je l'adore il a
tout ce qui va bien il est tellement
performant il est juste top 1029 € c'est
un gros budget mais si vous avez ce gros
budget et que vous voulez un smartphone
de gaming vous pouvez aller dessus alors
attention en photo c'est pas trop ça si
vous voulez quand même de très très
bonnes photos allez plutôt chez Honor ou
chez Samsung sur les modèles
ultra ou sur le S23 plus par exemple qui
sera top au niveau de la photo ici c'est
moins le cas mais si vous voulez de la
performance brute et un smartphone
vraiment orienté gaming avec ce qui se
fait le mieux aujourd'hui vous allez sur
le rockfon 7 et là franchement vous
serez pas déçu ce dernier que j'ai testé
que j'ai vraiment adoré c'est l'iPhone
14 pro max que j'utilise tous les jours
qui est un excellent smartphone
également alors une fois de plus on va
aller là-dessus parce que on veut ce qui
est mieux chez Apple parce qu'on veut
iOS parce qu'on a l'écosystème parce
qu'on a une Apple watch parce qu'on a
des airpods bref parce que on veut aller
chez Apple mais l'iPhone 14 pro max est
un excellent smartphone excellent
photophone excellent vidéophone beaucoup
de performances il est aujourd'hui pour
moi le plus puissant qu'on a sur le sur
le marché tout ce smartphone confondu et
je trouve vraiment très très bien la A16
elle est très très bonne beaucoup de
performances donc je veux pas vous faire
l'éloge de ce smartphone qui est juste
top donc si vous voulez aller chez Apple
vous le savez déjà si vous voulez un
iPhone 14 pro 14 pro max vous le savez
déjà vous n'êtes pas venu regarder cette
vidéo pour ça mais pour moi c'est
vraiment aussi un excellent smartphone
ici alors après deux smartphones qui
sont un peu particulier avec le Z fold 4
et le Z Philippe 4 là le zflip 4 voyez
on a une remise de fou à 799 €
d'ailleurs vous avez un zip 3 tout à
l'heure à 618 bon faut quand même
rajouter un peu d'argent mais là le prix
il est juste absolument canonissime a
moins de 800 balles vous avez cette flip
4 j'aurais dû le mettre dans l'autre
rubrique Comment je suis passé à côté
mais le tarif est fou et puis après bon
le Z fold 4 c'est un peu particulier
aussi comme format il reste quand même
cher on est un peu moins de 1500 balles
bon voilà mais c'est deux smartphones je
dirais que moi si on veut aujourd'hui un
pliable mon coup de cœur ça va aller sur
le Galaxy Z flip 3 vous êtes Philippe 4
de cette flip 4 sera mieux il sera plus
de choses et surtout à 799 € s'il vous
intéresse une fois de plus le lien est
en bas dans la description vous voyez on
a fait un tour complet j'essaie d'avoir
une vidéo un peu exhaustive de tout ce
qui existe on essaiera de faire
d'optimiser ce format de vidéo pour la
prochaine fois parce que je sais qu'il y
a quand même beaucoup de choses c'est
très dense ça fait une très longue vidéo
mais tous les mois promis je vous en
sort une comme ça d'ailleurs dites-moi
ça vous intéresse moi c'est ce format
vous plaît et est-ce que ça vous aura
aidé à venir acheter votre smartphone
oui donc en comment vous marquez ça en
bas en commentaire et on se retrouve
très vite pour continuer à parler de
plein de choses de texte et puis le mois
prochain pour guide d'achat pour venir
vous aider voilà je vous embrasse à
bientôt Ciao